(jaunty music)
- Where's she?
- Oh, you see Daniel Quan?
You see Janet right there?
She right there. She right there.
Hey, what's going on everybody?
We're gonna try to follow up Angela Patey.
And forgive us my counterpart
to great Chloe Zhao.
She's a little under the weather.
She's not contagious.
But I'm gonna do the lion's
share of the talking,
if that's okay.
So, and bear with me,
we gotta talk about somebody who we love,
a great deal and we gotta
talk through a little bit
of a broken heart.
So I ask for y'all, grace a little bit.
(crowd applause)
So I first met Michelle
Satter over the phone,
November 17th, 2001.
It was a conference call.
And I had learned that I was a finalist
for the Sundance Screenwriters Lab
that was taking place a few weeks later
on that next January before
the Film Festival in 2012.
And I was incredibly nervous.
I had heard about this program.
All of the filmmakers I admired had been
through this program.
They had been nurtured there.
I wanted to be a part of it.
I wanted to be accepted.
I was working on my film "Fruitvale"
and I was feeling really
like it was a big moment.
Chloe, you know this feeling?
- Yeah.
- And I got on the call
and folks were talking,
and all of a sudden I heard this voice.
It was like a magical voice
because immediately soon as
this person started talking,
all my anxiety faded away.
It was incredible.
And I was able to speak
clearly and think clearly.
And then as soon as we got off the call,
all the anxiety returned.
And I felt like I blew the
call and I blew my moment.
And I was amazed to hear
that I had been accepted a few days later.
And I was off to the right to this Lab.
I arrived at the Lab
and I think I was late.
- Yeah, you were.
- I was late, yeah.
- Yes. You were.
- Walking stereotype.
But I come in there late.
In a circle area, they're already talking.
And it's a fire and it's snow.
And I'm not, I'm a bay area guy
and I'm like excited
to see snow, you know.
And I sit down in this circle
and I feel, you know, deeply inadequate
and I missed everybody
introducing themselves.
So now it's my turn to introduce myself.
So I fumbled through that,
and then I hear that voice again,
and I see the person
that it's coming out of.
And that person was Michelle Satter.
And as soon as she started talking,
you could see like the whole
room's anxiety shift away.
And when that Lab started up,
I met all the staff
and everybody who was
working under her there,
they all seemed to kind of
embody that same vision,
that same spirit, was a comforting spirit.
And then I got to meet my Lab mates
and they showed us their movies.
And as soon as those movies rolled,
I felt deeply inadequate again, you know.
I was in there with a
guy named David Lowery,
a woman named Mario Heller,
and I was in there with the great,
Chloe Zhao,
and they played her movie.
And I was like, y'all
probably should switch jobs.
You know what I mean?
But again, we were mentored there
by incredible screenwriters
and filmmakers.
And we were mentored by each other.
We got share our scripts with everybody.
And I started to get the feeling
that maybe that group of
filmmakers might, you know,
might have a serious impact
on the world in this industry.
Shortly as a Screenwriter's
Lab was winding down
and we were getting ready
to go into the festival.
I had a meeting with Michelle,
where it was just me and her one-on-one.
I got to hear that voice
up close and personal,
you know, and it was amazing.
She asked me what I needed for my film.
I shared with her that
I was deeply terrified.
I thought I was about to be going.
And she said, "Well
look, you need a lawyer,
you need an agent, you need Craig.
And I can help you with
all of those things."
And it wasn't just words.
Within days, I was having
a meeting with my agent.
Who my agent now? Craig Castell.
I met my lawyer now who's done
all of my deals since then.
And she set us up with Craig
and we were ready to get going.
She was just like a complete
bridge for us who were,
you know, young artists
coming outta school
and coming outta, you know,
never having done this before.
Bridge that's into believing
that we could do
something in this industry
and maintain our voice.
Fast forward a few months later,
I shot my film
and I was sharing the
film around with people,
and everybody was giving
me feedback saying
that they liked it.
And then I sent the film to Michelle,
and I'll never forget where
I was when I called her
to get feedback.
I was standing on the
corner in East Oakland.
And I was ready for that soothing voice
to give me all kinds of confidence.
And she tore that film apart, man.
It was the first time I
heard that voice weaponized.
You know what I mean?
It was like you gotta fix
this and this isn't working.
And maybe change this,
this scene is all a place, you know,
this movie needs to feel
like this, this, this,
that, this, and this ain't working.
And I'm like, man,
who is this person on the
other side of the phone?
You know? And I, again,
inadequacy comes back and
I feel like a failure.
I feel like I let Michelle down.
And then the last thing she says to me is,
"Hey, make sure you get a
good night's sleep tonight.
You sound like you haven't been sleeping.
I've been there, you know,
a good night's sleep.
You may be a look at things
differently in the morning."
Took her advice.
And I went back to the editing
and saw that every single one
of her notes was the real deal.
And I realized this was the first person
who was watching the film
and giving me feedback
that actually cared about
me and cared about the film.
She was incredible.
And we went to Sundance Film Premieres.
And leading up into that,
she made the most incredible introduction
that she's ever made for me.
We had been been accepted to the festival.
And she gives me a call and she says,
"Hey, do you guys have anybody
running your social media?"
And I didn't even have a MySpace.
I didn't have a social media.
I was very deficient in this category.
And she says, "You know,
you're gonna need one for your film."
She says, "I'd like you to meet somebody
who I think would be great for you."
Who's our son? Michael Latt.
And Michael was a ex-football
player in high school.
He was a Star Quarterback.
And she knew I played football coming up,
who was just coming up outta Chapman
and was very proficient
with Social Media Marketing.
She thought he'd be perfect for us,
and I wanted to meet anybody
who's remotely related to Michelle.
You know what I'm saying? So I was like,
I'll let her sit down with him.
And Michael just blew us away.
He built the most incredible
social media campaign
for our film before it was even acquired.
Once we was acquired,
the distribution company kept him on,
made him professional at it.
And he and I got to collaborate
outside of the film ministry
to start "Black of Human Rights"
and do all types of
social justice advocacy
and find an intersection
between the arts and activism.
Michael's work changed the world.
To know him.
(crowd applause)
To know him,
was to know Michelle,
was to know his father, David,
was to know his brother, Frankly.
And since his life was cut short,
I've realized to know them,
is to know Michael.
Michelle, you changed our lives.
But you, yeah,
I do believe Michael was your
greatest gift to the world.
And every time I talk to you,
every time I'm in your presence,
it feels like he's still here with us.
- Thank you, Ryan.
Michelle, you're a mother to me.
And you're a mother to Ryan,
and you're a mother to so many
people sitting in this room.
You're a mother to all this artist
that you have nurtured and supported.
We're so grateful to you.
We wouldn't be here without you.
We know you're hurting.
We're so sorry.
And we know that there's
nothing we can say
that can take away the pain.
But we want to say
and we hope we can say this to you,
we are all your children.
We are all your children.
We love you.
(crowd applause)
We love you so, so much.
And we will stand by you.
Always.
(crowd applause)
(bright music)